hey everybody welcome back to LED live
where we are gonna expose some darkness
with the light of Christ and we are very
excited about our guests here today
Randi and Julia thank you so much for
being with us well thanks for letting us
come so way have you guys ever
experienced any interaction with the
new-age not that I know of I think you'd
be surprised yeah I would agree with
Randi I think more people than not have
come into contact with New Age
philosophies New Age ideas so we want to
get to the bottom of this what is it and
we want to know your guys's experience
so stick around stay tuned led live
we're gonna talk about the New Age find
out on this episode of LED live so thank
you guys for coming on the show and we
actually have discussed kind of the New
Age in different little LEDs from time
to time comes up obviously in a lot in
in the Hollywood subject and so you know
you guys have had some experience in
this area so why don't you tell us a
little bit about your background and you
know how did you guys even get involved
in the whole New Age movement well
actually it's kind of interesting how it
happens because you really don't know
that it's happening because the kind of
you fall into it gradually I grew up in
a Lutheran family my mother and father
were very much involved with the church
in the beginning and so forth so it was
something that you you know you do on an
everyday basis and then I love science
fiction okay I was a science fiction
addict and then you know I was reading
all those wonderful things that you know
in science fiction that you probably
really shouldn't be doing anyways
because it actually leads you
systematically into the New Age movement
then I really got involved with that
series with you know Gandalf and the
Lord of the Rings and all and that
really you know was like a kicker for me
to a great extent and then what happened
as as you as we were progressing I was
getting older actually
and in fact when I was at the University
of Michigan I was going to school there
you know you have your Halloween routine
I great I dressed up as Gandalf it was
kind of scary how about that was like
the role I'm serious it was really wild
but anyways you know we that's how that
shows you how it became pervasive
already at that time right and and it
was really a big thing and when I was
going I had the book and everything you
know yeah it was everything you know as
I was kind of doing a little research
for this and floating through YouTube
videos and just listening to testimonies
of other kids I was actually surprised
how many young people had gotten
involved in the New Age movement and how
they all began literally exactly like
you're explaining started reading books
started messing around with Harry Potter
started messing around with anything
that Hollywood was kind of putting out
and that was the introduction with wow
this might be kind of interesting and
then as they looked deeper into it they
fell into it
well there's that's where the next step
comes actually because my mom and dad
they became very disenfranchised with
the Lutheran Church some things happened
within the church and my dad said I
don't have anything to do with him
anymore
and he became a Mason eventually became
a 32nd degree Mason interesting and what
happened then is my mom started feeding
me things okay and they have my sister
is still very much into it she that's
where I started experiencing things like
Joel Goldsmith in course of miracles mmm
Alice Bailey
Elena Blavatsky Nicholas Rarick you know
the list goes on which those those names
for anybody of our listeners that don't
know are heavily involved in the New Age
movement especially Alice a is it Alice
a Bailey that is the that the curriculum
for the world
yes exactly system is now beginning to
be built that is correct
mmm that's where they had the I remember
going to their office in New York City
mhm
before they got transferred from it was
over there on the east side and then it
moved from there to the United Nations
building and so they actually have in
the United Nations building you've got
you know yeah the Theosophical Society
which is the foundation for a lot of
what is the educational system that we
have today
and now it's still currently heavily
active right now from
what my understanding is I didn't go
back to double-check but when I was
there you know that the Nicholas Rarick
a lot of the art from Nicholas art for
example you would find in the
Theosophical society and on their walls
and so forth and how they all combined
and can blend you know from the infinite
way but written by Joe Goldsmith and
then you have the books written by Alice
Bailey and and
Helena Blavatsky and that basically they
were channeling someone okay this is
where the channeling starts to come in
this is where for example the course of
miracles was all all channeled you have
her books basically were child du'a fool
it's interesting name event wash cool
but he was it was the entity that they
were channeling hmm and he had all this
really mystical information and Alice
Bailey herself became a 32nd degree
Mason and so you have all these
different things that you put together
in fact you when you go to the museum
and the Nicollet I the Theosophical sigh
music and their books where they have
all their books you'll see a picture of
who they're in they're in regalia in G
hands on and so it's really
intellectually it's stimulating because
it gets your mind going down different
ways you know it's really cool that you
you have all this wonderful seemingly
wonderful information but really what it
does is it focuses on your ability
remember Shirley MacLaine mm-hmm I I
remember her at one point and remember
walking down the beach and saying I am
God yeah it's distinctly okay and and
and that's where that all comes from
yeah there's a connection between all
that stuff is astounding so at the core
of New Age it's all about I am God and
it's kind of the end goal of what
they're getting at personally and so the
attraction to that somebody that is
quote-unquote spiritual or you know
looking to have a relationship with a
with something greater than themselves
it sounds attractive well it's often
called the higher self right right which
is kind of God right boils back down to
the old self always right yeah exactly
in fact that's where I what I'm you know
when we were testing them the Mike's out
I was reading to you from the great
invocation yeah do you mind if I read
that yeah it's actually pretty short
he's not there
but this is something that you would
actually sit down and you would meditate
on this okay now listen to this this is
now this is a new age this is this is
the the core of from the Theosophical
society okay okay and this is what this
is from the new way just to be you could
actually say this is the mantra for the
New Age movement okay okay Lord protect
my ears okay this is from the point of
light within the mind of God let light
stream forth into the minds of men let
light descend on the earth now that
sounds really wonderful to us right okay
from the from the point of love within
the heart of God let love stream forth
into the hearts of men may Christ return
to the earth okay so you see all this
blending coming in okay if you weren't
if you weren't studying that sounds
great it's not it's really powerful
stuff okay and then we go into the next
paragraph assist from the center where
the will of God is known let purpose
guide the little wills of men the
purpose which the Masters now and know
and serve the Masters know and serve all
of a sudden now we've taken a left turn
yeah okay so you have this entrance that
makes it really comfortable if you're a
Christian to go ahead and accept it but
now you have these masters oh this is
really cool mm-hmm so the Masters aren't
linked to to Jesus and go no no no see
they're their masters are now all of a
sudden you've gone from Christ to having
masters that teach you all about Christ
and these are ascended masters Josh cool
was an ascended master I mean that's
where you get like you know we've kind
of looked into the whole Eastern
influence through the martial arts and
and there's always this master element
someone that has ascended to this you
know higher learning and and and they're
there now lording over other people it's
interesting and then we have what - one
last paragraph here pretty much it says
from the center which will which we call
the race of men let the plan of love and
light work out and may it seal the door
where evil dwells that light and love
and power restore the plan on earth my
plan right right right
whose plan yeah that's a good point you
know see these are the questions you
need to start asking and now notice what
it says here this is the statement that
they have at the end of this the great
invocation it says many religions
believe in a world teacher a coming one
knowing him under such names as the Lord
tria okay you've heard that name
probably right matreya
imam mahdi which is the muslim aspect of
it okay cut as a colleague cut the cocky
cocky avatar and Bodhi svaha the terms
are sometimes in versions of the great
invocation for people a specific path
now avatar as in like that's the word or
just using the word as the Dictionary
describes like an avatar overtaking
someone's body or they're looking for an
avatar they're looking for an avatar
that's kind of interesting in light of
like some of these clips we'll see later
on
okay so this is absolutely fascinating
that all of a sudden you have this this
terminology that's being used we've
heard of avatar which isn't some of the
things that can be showing later on and
that all of a sudden you make all these
connections so you think that you're
going something that you have something
really interesting well the thing is is
that what attracts people to it would
attracted me to it initially it's
because you know you have this secret
right okay you have this secret
something that nobody else yeah I feel
kind of like you're walking around like
I know something that everyone else yeah
exactly so how did you how did you get
involved in it obviously we were we got
involved with it very separately cuz I
was almost 35 when we met and I my
involvement started when I was about 12
and I was in a church-going family and
around that age I was starting to become
really attracted to Christ and I think
that's been the devil made his move
right I I don't remember the exact
sequence of events but I think probably
the first thing was my oldest sister
went away for a year abroad and my
brother and other sister discovered her
Ouija board
and we started playing around with that
oh boy
and we we just thought it was the
coolest thing and did you did it do
anything yeah my sister and I would put
our hands on the thing and you'd feel it
move yeah we just move around like oh
this is so cool
did it answer questions yeah that's
scary and then at the same time I was
always a bookworm so I feel like I
didn't come into the New Age through the
medium of television
so much his third books but in those
days this was the early 70s the those
tabloids like the National Enquirer oh
yeah like nowadays it's all just like
celebrity gossip but in those days it
had a lot of her always articles about
psychics stuff UFOs there are
advertisements for you know psychic
books and so I would read that and I was
influenced by that and then I also found
a book by a psychic and at the
supermarket waiting online hmm and it
introduced me to reincarnation
and I thought wow this is totally cool
because I I didn't like the I didn't
like the hell thing I would I would
think about this and think well I I just
didn't see how is this it just didn't
seem right that God would send us to
this eternally burning hell just based
on this little lifetime under right then
so then when I learned about
reincarnation it was like oh yeah this
makes sense this seemed fair I mean ooh
you reap the karma that you sow in this
life in your egg slice right so once I
for me that was author my years of being
in the mewing that was the one constant
really was the belief in reincarnation
because I I went on I'm I didn't
approach it as intellectually as you did
I was more into the experiencial stuff
like martial arts and Buddhist
meditation yoga I lived in a yoga ashram
for almost a couple years so that was
kind of my did you ever get into the
Kundalini well um it was sort of the
heyday of the ashram had kind of already
passed as far as Kundalini but
apparently in the early days of that
ashram by the time I was there there
were like 300 residents and in the early
days apparently people had a lot of
these Kundalini experiences and but I
remember this one time where the Guru
was chanting and we were all doing like
yoga pose and and everybody just started
like simultaneously like like like
shouting or explained like just
these deep yellow coming up from the
interest you know and and it was very
ecstatic to and the other thing that how
I got into it to begin with was that I
visited the ashram just to take a yoga
workshop for the weekend and and the
Guru was there and they would have these
evening meetings where everybody
gathered and and would sing these chants
like there's really repetitive chance
and and beat drums and stuff and dance
and and so it's like we danced and
chanted ourselves into this frenzy and
then by the time the Guru came in it was
I don't know how to explain it it was
something like love at first sight it's
like you know it's like I was just
immediately taken in by the Guru and
interested you know why that's kind of
interesting
we just did an LED on a little kids
cartoon yeah remember how the music and
everybody was like all I can aw over the
main character ugly dolls I don't know
just something that sparked me because
they had this real impactful scene where
everybody was playing all this music and
then in walk to the main character and
everybody was just like ah in love with
him but it was really the music and
everything that was kind of driving that
interesting so music has a very
important part to play that's that's why
I've always been since becoming a
Christian man somewhat uncomfortable
with some of the worship you know right
right involving weight music especially
when there's drums and everybody goes
into this kind of ecstatic almost like
it right minds me too much of that right
cuz you're there you recognize it and
you say hey hey hey this is this is from
something else you know that was kind of
like the thing that really woke me up
with with yoga thing it's like you know
if you never really heard any
testimonies or anybody that that was
Hindu or you know it's like hey it just
sounds like some you know natural poses
and and you know you're doing it but
when you when you really sit down and
listen to what the Hindus say I mean
it's like it's part of their practice so
it like is awkward to them when they
watch it too because they're like wait
wait this is just like my religion over
here very interesting well I want to
share with you guys a couple of clips
here I want to I want to I want to set
this up by playing you a couple of clips
from from Oprah Winfrey you guys have
probably seen these clips she being a
person that is very high-profile in in
Hollywood and is kind of pushing a new
age um idea and philosophy you guys
probably see in this clip where she
basically talks about there's many ways
to to get to God listen to this it talks
about one of the points it brings out is
one of the mistakes that human beings
make is believing that there is only one
way to live and that we don't accept
that there are diverse ways of being in
the world that there are millions of
ways to be a human being and many ways
don't but many paths to what you call
God that her path might be something
else and when she gets there she might
call it the life but her loving and her
kindness and her generosity brings her
if it brings her to the same point that
it brings you it doesn't matter whether
she called it god along the way or not
and I guess the danger that could be on
that I mean it sounds great on the onset
but if you really look at both sides I'd
probably be just one way what what about
you what about Jesus is one way and only
one way and that is you say you
intellectualize it and say there isn't
if you don't believe that you're all
buying into the line I have something
that that brought up for me is that
author of the years when I was in the
New Age it's like I was constantly
getting into this or that new fad I'd go
from Buddhism to a more Western new
ageism to something else and and it's
like it it was all perfectly in harmony
with each other and then you know we we
got married and about a year after we
got married was when we first came into
the church it was like suddenly this was
the first time I was faced with a total
paradigm shift this did not fit in with
any of the other things that I passed
that I'd been on it wasn't just the
smooth transition from one right back to
another it was right at least something
completely
doesn't fit here yeah yeah everybody
wants to come to Christ or elevate they
want to have this relationship with God
that's really what attracted me to the
new age it's because you want to have
this relationship so does make any
difference how you get there right as
long as you get there that's really what
she's saying but there is a process by
which you get there and that's a
commitment to the understanding of who
Christ is what scripture has to say you
see the Lord is gonna bring you from
many different directions which is the
truth okay but what they're saying is
well it doesn't make any difference how
you get there as long as you get there
okay okay that's a big difference yeah
but it raises a lot of questions like
where are we going mm you know are we
all talking about the same place exactly
because the Muslims aren't necessarily
talking about the same place as the
Christians aren't necessarily talking
about the same place as the Buddhist so
like what place are we talking about and
when we get there who's gonna be there
hmm
you know I mean is it is it all these
Cosmic Christ types hmm or is it Jesus
hmm because if you say it's Jesus then
no no it's a whole different thing right
like now you're saying I can get to
heaven and at the end God is gonna be
there but but but who is God mmm you
know you're raising a lot of really you
know big questions the book of Ephesians
tells us there's one faith one Lord one
baptism right it doesn't tell us there's
many it says there's one and Jesus also
told us he's like you know there's
there's a narrow way hmm
and there's a broad way mmm he says few
people finding their way so it's not
this catch-all whatever you want to
believe everyplace leads to the same
place the Bible is very clear that
that's not the way it works and I think
if you put yourself in this position of
well whatever you know they all lead to
the same place doesn't matter what I
believe as long as I get to this this
place in the end if you have a singular
entity that you're dealing with Jesus
Christ then you have to submit yourself
to that mm-hmm and I don't think a lot
of people want to do that I think they
want to be more open I think they want
to be I think they want to put
themselves
position where I can still do what I
want you know I got it
morality doesn't matter so much there's
not there's not this set of rules or
ideals or curriculum or whatever you
want to call it that I have to submit
myself to you I'm just gonna I'm gonna
hold back is I want to do my own thing
so if I can get where I want to go doing
my own thing that that's the way I
prefer I don't want to submit to
somebody in the simple case of Hinduism
there's what 300 yeah 300 million
millions gods it's not just like 300 is
like 300 million gods and it's like can
I have all of these gods and you know
that clashes with Exodus 20 verse 2 and
3 you know it's like have no other gods
before you and you know you can't
reconcile those two together so if the
Bible's telling you listen you can't
have any other gods that's breaking
god's holy 10 commandments yet you have
all these other religions that say no no
that's okay
how do you rectify that it doesn't the
one thing from my from my perspective
anyways the real issue
you were bringing up was really powerful
in it that struck home and this is
really the issue it's one word
it's called sin because what happens is
that you're in the New Age movement you
don't have to deal with that issue okay
you know when you come to Christ you
have to deal with that issue
you had that require submission mm-hmm
and that's really what the issue is
whether we want to look at it any other
way we can look at it and call it
different names or what however you want
to call it but the bottom line is is sin
mm-hmm how do we deal with that issue
and the only way you can deal with that
issue through submission to Christ and
allowing him to heal you and bring you
that peace that you're longing for and
that's really what the New Age movement
is looking for they're looking for peace
all right you saw that in the invocation
they're looking for love right all those
things are looking for but what they
what they're avoiding we're not dealing
with is your own heart and the deity are
dealing with the issue of sin right it's
just knowledge will bring you to that
that's a higher place it has nothing to
do with actually that moral you know
choices their compass that's a very
Gnostic that's right yeah that's right
listen to what Galatians 2:16 says
knowing that man is not justified by the
works of the law but by faith in Jesus
Christ even we have believed in Jesus
Christ that we might be justified
by faith in Christ and not by the works
of the law for by the works of the law
no flesh shall be justified the reason I
threw this person here is because Oprah
made a really good interesting point at
the very end she said what about the
people that live in the middle of the
Amazon that have never heard of Christ
right mmm right right so they're living
up to the light that they can that's
that's that's true I really believe that
there will be people in heaven that have
never heard the name of Jesus they're
gonna be coming up going what Jesus who
who's this but in our current situation
in our current world and having majority
of this country knows about God has at
least heard about coming and so to say
that you can choose and pick and have
all this plethora on the table here I
think is very dangerous theology agreed
I think one of the things that turn me
off Christianity was that Christians a
lot of Christians really aren't living
up to the light that we have and I
wasn't attracted to that I went to a
pretty we were going to a pretty liberal
Church where we started looking it was
in a rich part of the country and it was
you know just the social club mm-hmm and
I I didn't I didn't see anything and in
my family we didn't really we didn't
have family worship we didn't read the
Bible together or pray together you know
obviously you get into reading and books
and being an avid reader weren't
probably reading the Bible so I did read
my children's Bible growing up so there
you go there you go but you need that
line and you need that foundation
because you know you stumble across it
this stuff sounds great you're gonna
fall into it yeah it's interesting
because yesterday I was the got one of
the guys that I work with he says what
are you going tomorrow I said what we're
going to be talking to some people who
got a documentary that they're doing on
the New Age movement he says no way
explain that to me and I said well you
know we're going through that
explanation right now but his issue was
he didn't really what what does it
really mean to be a Christian he was a
Christian and when I start
talking to him about what it really
meant to be a Christian it like whoa he
was a Christian when he was realizing
for example tithing okay
I can't tithe because I lived from
paycheck to paycheck mm-hmm my house is
paid for but I still live from paycheck
to paycheck well that's the whole point
Christ will provide for you if you're
willing to trust in him and faith in Him
you see that's really what the issue is
here you you trust in the masters that
we're gonna go ahead and lead you into
all truth
okay but are they really gonna lead you
in all truth they're gonna keep you in
and that's really what happened with me
in the New Age movement I found myself
going from one person to another person
to another person and foreign trying to
understand exactly what is this meaning
and then you begin to realize that what
you have when you brought out the book
morals and Dogma a little bit earlier
you said it it has it has the Bible
mixed in with this language that really
is confusing and that's really if you
really sit down and take a look at what
is being said you realize that it's not
taking you anywhere okay it's like
circles yeah it goes all over the place
it's really intellectually stimulating
right okay but really what is the bottom
line result right where is it going to
take you and are you going to have a
true relationship with Christ in the
process or with God period that's right
and that doesn't take you there that's
right so what you said you know we have
to build that foundation it made me
think of another scripture which was in
1st Corinthians 3 it says for no other
foundation can anyone lay than that
which is laid which is Jesus Christ
clearly tells us what our foundation is
supposed to be that's right and John
Ford 14:6 has I am the way the truth and
the life no man comes to the Father
except through me and we know God cannot
lie so if he's saying this you know I
mean the foundation is God and Jesus and
he's the only way so the statement that
Oprah was making to me is is a very
dangerous statement what does do that
does the New Age movement claim that
their foundation is Jesus Christ they
claim their foundation I'll give you the
example my father was a 32nd degree
Mason and one day he was trying to
recruit me to become a Mason this is
after I become a Sunday
and he said well Randy we accept all
religions I said fantastic
and he said we even have a Bible in the
center of our lodge
I said that's even that's great that and
I asked him one question he never ever
asked me again
whether I would want to become the Mason
or not I asked him one question and the
question was this do you read it
hmmm that stopped it he never again
asked me to become a Mason mm-hmm
so the issue in masonry itself even
though it's accepts all religions what
is the core focus obviously it's not the
Bible because they don't read it right
his lack of submission of saying that
yeah we do read it tells me that they
don't read it okay it's almost like the
Christian cross that all the rappers are
using I mean we were watching some some
Christian rapper the other day and then
looking at one of his music videos and I
mean either like turn away and and here
he is a self professed Christian and
it's like what does that cross mean to
you I mean if it's just a symbol and you
have it out there it doesn't mean
anything if the Bible is on the table
but you don't read it it doesn't mean
anything
in an I mean as far as your question I
don't remember the New Age ever talking
about Jesus as being the foundation but
they will talk about Jesus or the Christ
and but he's just another enlightened
being maybe an ascended master he's he
I've read stories about well Jesus was
reincarnated makino per month from this
Tibetan master or there's a night pop
there's an idea that Jesus went to Tibet
to study with this so for someone who
may not be familiar with the New Age
movement is there a distinguishing
factor because it kind of sounds like
they're kind of they're accepting of all
so they're bringing all this all these
different religions they're probably
taking from all these different ones
they talk about different aspects of
different religions but what is their
end goal what's their distinguishing
mark what are they trying to achieve
what they're trying to achieve from my
perspective anyways okay when I when I
look at this and if you have any
thoughts we'd like to hear it as well
too is that it's really actually taking
you away from Christ that's the ultimate
goal but it's hidden but it's hidden
okay
okay in other words it's just like the
guy when I was talking to him yesterday
says well tell me about the New Age
movement I said how can I explain that
to you because it covers such a wide
expanse of area and territory to go
ahead and define us specifically it's
next to impossible because you're gonna
find the New Age movement in movies
you're gonna find it in books you're
gonna find it in science fiction you're
gonna find it across the spectrum of
life as a whole others have a tendency
to target certain areas intellectually
for example the Theosophical society our
Alice Bailey and her and her material
that's the very intellectual end of it
but then you have those that are you
know let's just walk along as far as
Christianity is concerned you have
Christianity that's very new age because
you don't have that commitment when
there is not that commitment and
recognizing your need for Christ and
submission to him you're walking into
the into that and to basically into
blackness in the darkness because all of
them are selling you on the idea that
that there's either an afterlife or
there's an achievement that you can get
to there's something greater than what
you are experiencing now that you you
know you want to get to a higher state I
mean in Christianity that would be
obviously going to heaven there's
something greater than what we're
experiencing here right so the New Age
movement is pushing people in that
direction as well but basically removing
that Jesus is really the only way and
that you know there's all these
different ways to achieve that is that
kind of what I'm hearing exactly I don't
think I had a clear goal of where I
wanted to go as a New Ager I just knew
that I didn't want to cease to exist
I wanted to keep living hmm and that's
why reincarnation was appealing and yeah
achieving higher states had its appeal
but the main thing was just forever I
didn't want to die yeah I want to
deliver it well acts 4:12 says nor is
there is there salvation in any other
for there is no other name under heaven
given among men which we must be saved
there's one yeah there's another thing
that I think that you find in the New
Age is that one of the reasons that they
don't like Christianity is because they
feel are being judged
hmm
but and that's one of the things that he
was asking me yesterday as well too and
I said well Matthew chapter 7 says judge
not lest ye be judged by what judgment
you mete out so shall you be judged very
clear and so when I told that to them
it's like whoa
made it a minute here that's really what
the core of Christianity is we are not
to judge anyone we have no right to
because we're a sinner just like anyone
elses and that's really what makes
Christianity more attractive when you
have that kind of mindset but what has
happened with Christianity has become
what very judgemental as a whole no
degree you know and we have a tense you
look at people and we judge them for
whatever their position is what they
don't have or what they do have or where
they are in life or color they are
whatever the situation might be and
instead of accepting them who they are
for example there are people that hate
Muslims wait a minute here mm-hmm they
are just as there are no different they
have that right to Christ just as much
as we do as it a theist does or anyone
else does if we have a religion that
actually reveals that character of
Christ guess what happens people will
come flocking to it like they're looking
at it in the New Age they will come out
of the New Age I remember one time I was
on an airplane and I was coming back
from I can't remember I think money but
coming back from Arizona and I was
sitting next to this guy and we were
talking back and forth and and he said
done well I came out of the New Age this
is what you came out of the new it you
can't I mean he was in shock he was in
complete shock he was in the corner so
it's like he had no way to escape and he
was reading a new age book and the poor
guy put him into shock you know you did
he was completely flabbergasted how can
anybody come out of the New Age movement
you know and and the reason that I that
we basically came out of New Age
movement was we discovered a faith in
Christ that was accepting you know does
that mean that we don't have our
problems no that's not true at all but
the focal point and the true essence of
who Christ is is discovered that way
it's a good point good point that's what
a lot of people are searching for I want
to kind of continue on here with a
little bit
where Oprah is going with this because
this is some of the the mentality that
is being pushed out into the world and
what's more alarming to me as you're
beginning to start to see a blend of New
Age philosophy and Christianity and that
little merger of the two of those
together is is is something that you
know I was pretty shocked coming across
some videos on YouTube that how many
people had fallen into this just
searching around on YouTube I mean you
look at you look at the the the young
kids that really get into the into this
it just began with just searching out
like Christian themed things and it
steered towards that you know the
suggestions of the other videos that
came up and some of guys so I kind of
give a little background here's a little
clip from Oprah where she's trying to
describe this blend of Christianity well
I am a Christian who believes that there
are there are certainly many more paths
to God other than Christianity
I'm a free-thinking Christian who
believes in my way but I don't believe
that it's the only way what I believe is
that Jesus came to show us Christ
consciousness okay you know now have you
heard of this term Christ consciousness
yes what is this you want to go well I
don't know but this blending of
Christianity and it's nothing new I mean
that's been going on for a long time
yeah for a long time when I was about 14
I became interested in the books of
Edgar Cayce it was a New Age prophet and
he really blended yeah he was probably
if you ever heard him before it was a
sleeping prophet over in Virginia Beach
hmm as they have their headquarters
right there around 55th Street or
something like that hmm and beautiful
place you know I overlooked and he lived
in the time he did he passed away around
World War two so he was old so that was
his time and he was a Christian he
considered himself to be a Christian you
read the Bible and read the Bible you're
open
and but he would he was called the
sleeping prophet while the sleeping
prophet what he would do is he would
have if a person had a problem with say
in California he would go into a trance
and he would actually prescribe what the
problems were with that person and would
if they were followed the prescription
that was given to him which was guess
what natural remedies mm-hmm it started
with his own health problem because he
he he got desperate and decided to try
hypnosis and that's how he started like
going into these trances and and that's
you know and when you say and they've
got all these writings and he you know
he talked about Atlantis and Muno you
know all these different things about
the past that affect us today and and
absolutely fascinating but yet those
remedies that he came up with I still
they actually still use them they're
still work and he would he would
encourage people to continue going to
church reading all this metaphysical
stuff
yeah which to me is fascinating it's
like you know the devil is just so
slippery it's like he kind of gets in
there and he tinker's with the mindset a
little bit but he's like no no just keep
going to church you know it's okay
you'll be fine
tweaking yeah he just shifts the mind a
little bit so here's my question you
know for the for the viewers the Bible
tells us that we should have the mind of
Christ what is the difference between
that and Christ consciousness as she
says well now we're going into
esotericism because all of a sudden you
have this huge mind of Christ where we
come together we unify this way and then
we all somehow mystically connect with
one another okay I can lighten
enlightenment yeah it's it's like you
know for us as a Christian you have that
peace with Christ okay you're you have
you have basically Christ in you the
hope of glory okay that's the same kind
of a concept but now we're taking in a
different direction okay we're taking it
away from the focal point of Christ and
we're saying this Christ consciousness
you know what what does that mean how do
you define
very focused on self yeah what you have
to do going with in listening to Oprah's
comment reminded me of what you were
saying before any about your talking
with a Christian but you come to find
out that they don't really know what
Christianity is all about being a
Christian is a follower of Christ and
worth saying that you know Jesus came to
earth to show us his consciousness but I
still believe there's a whole bunch of
other ways to Christ as if that whole
process was just a suggestion like Jesus
was saying oh well this is one way you
know you can do others but this is
ignore that right so I'll define it
using Oprah's words that Jesus actually
taught me Christ consciousness is who to
be fully human used to be christ-like
yeah and so it's not anytime that you
not follow your spiritual calling that
you are lesser of a human
yes I'm Christian too and I got that a
long time ago I was mentioned this also
in this book called discovered the power
within you by Eric Butterworth where he
talks about the Christ consciousness and
up until then I was like you Marquis I
thought Jesus came died on the cross
that Jesus is being here was about his
death and dying on the cross when it
really was about him coming to show us
how to do it how to be to show us the
Christ consciousness that he had and
that that consciousness abides with all
of us that's what I got what what Christ
consciousness to her is is Christ was
the model he's the way he realized he
was divine and that we can now model
ourselves after how he awoken himself to
be divine we can awaken to be divine
does that make sense yes so the
consciousness that Christ was like at 12
years old oh wow I'm God like all of a
sudden you now have that opportunity to
be able to do that sure that's actually
describes it it's just thing why do you
need Christ if you're God that's that
that's the end yeah that's that's the
end goal so she has a show called super
soul Sunday ever
the show narrator the show very
interesting she takes on all these
people onto her show and she just has
this sit down conversation with him and
it's usually about spiritual or
Christianity or thought or whatever
right so here's a little compilation of
she's asking them all the question what
does God mean to you listen how the
analyst sorry when you say them these of
different faiths different people well
these are people who Ya Ya I don't know
what their actual faith background
without watching the show but okay this
is this is what she's trying to like
really get the bottom of who God is what
is your definition of God God is the
highest place within each and every one
of us it's our divine self I define God
as an energy a spiritual energy it has
no denomination it has no judgments it
has an energy that one more connected to
it we know why we're here and what we're
here to do well here's my beloved he is
my most intimate beloved my friend the
one I looked to in everything I wouldn't
try to define him because no one knows
God but God he is beyond even our idea
of the beyond what is your definition of
God all that is everything everything
breath life everything I I can't even
just get Webster's dictionary throw it
on the floor everything everything and
God is in everything God is everything
not only in is everything sounds like
they're running away from something
you know from absolute truth you can you
can hear the very beginnings of where
this is starting to go where the actual
end goal of the New Age movement like
you guys have said is really doing it's
it's it's a stepping away from Christ
exactly it's a stepping away of the
focal point being on this beam and being
like we can self realize and come to
this understanding I I brought that up
because I want to play this little clip
of this youtuber that to me is why we
why we decided to do this show in the
first place I
think this is a cautionary tale to
parents who allow their children to play
with YouTube literally because I know
I've kind of said this a couple of times
these kids are jumping on YouTube and
it's suggesting videos to you so she has
quite a few followers and she kind of
got she's a Christian so she does little
vlogs and stuff about Christianity and
the production company to a wrinkle in
time reached out to her and asked her to
do something for them so I'll let her
tell the story so a New Age religion has
been all over the place lately I've just
seen it everywhere I feel like
everyone's talking about it everyone's
starting to believe that way especially
here on YouTube
I know a lot of youtubers who seem to be
kind of getting into that way of
thinking and I've even had some
subscribers who have been struggling
with falling into that belief system as
well and then this past Sunday I went
and saw the movie A Wrinkle in time by
Disney and all of this together has led
to the video I'm making today so about
New Age something I've noticed is that a
lot of people who fall into the belief
system of New Age religion used to be
Christians Oprah for example used to be
Baptist and now she's like a huge
advocate for New Age beliefs there's two
videos I'm gonna leave linked below that
are actually people who were Christian
went to New Age religion and came back
to Christianity but about a year ago
actually I got an email from the people
associated with the movie a wrinkle in
time and they were looking for a bunch
of Christian influencers to promote the
movie back then there wasn't really a
whole lot of information about it I just
looked up the movie and from what I saw
I thought that there was something about
witchcraft in it and so I was kind of
just like yeah you know I didn't get a
good feeling about it so I decided not
to go through with that which I'm glad
that I didn't even though there wasn't
any witchcraft in the movie but yeah
they were specifically looking for
Christian people to promote the movie
which I thought was interesting and then
on my facebook I actually saw a
sponsored ad for like a devotional
course to go through the movie and then
see how it correlates to Christianity
and like what you can learn from it and
I was really confused about that as well
so all of that together along with all
of the people that have fallen away from
Christianity to this religion and the
subscribers that have reached out to me
about this has kind of led me to think
that the New Age religion
is really an attack on Christianity and
that Satan is really trying to use this
to get people to fall away from faith in
Jesus so exactly like what you guys you
guys obviously haven't seen this clip
know exactly like what you're saying
she's coming to the same realization and
and here's something that's kind of
interesting so this is CBN News and this
is what the the article says on their
website the writer of Disney's wrinkle
in time ditches Bible biblical themes
for a lot of new-age content now have
you guys ever looked into this movie no
no never never seen the trailers I'm
always curious to read the book when I
was a kid but I never read it okay so
did you know that the writer was was was
quote-unquote scrren not enough the
writer of Disney's wrinkle in time is
defending her decision to move Christian
themes away from the movie she removed
references to Jesus and various biblical
passages from the film adaptation of I
can't say that Madeline L angles popular
book of the same name she says for a
message of inclusiveness so they removed
these these things of Jesus even though
there's all this like magical and
sorcery and things that are that are in
there that just a lot of things that are
that are that are wrong with this movie
in the first place but I just thought it
was really interesting that they were
trying to put like like things of Jesus
in there and they took it out for a
message of inclusiveness but but after
now going back to this young girl
Savannah that was getting suggested in
her feed like as she was like wait a
minute like they reached out they wanted
Christian influencers to influence
people to go and see this and you see
how see how slippery this is and
obviously Oprah is in this movie she's
was heavily involved in the making of
this film let's talk about Avatar mmm
you know you brought that up earlier
avatar has a connection with with with
the New Age and have you guys never seen
this movie
bits and pieces bits and pieces I've
seen bits and pieces of it as well and
very interesting if you just look up
what in the dictionary definition what
and avatar is in dictionary calm it
means a descent of a deity down to earth
so I find it pretty interesting that
that obviously is the title of the this
very major movie and they're making a
couple of sequels that are coming out
and but this is chock-full of New Age
theology the New York Times there was a
writer that wrote for the New York Times
and he was talking a little bit about
this whole Avatar series and listen to
the language that he that he puts in
here he says it's fitting that James
Cameron's Avatar arrives in theaters at
Christmastime like the holiday season
itself the science fiction epic is a
crass embodiment of a capitalistic
excess wrapped around a deeply felt
religious message it's at once the
blockbuster to end all blockbusters and
the Gospel according to James not the
Christian gospel instead avatar is
Cameron's long apologia for pantheism a
faith that equates God with nature and
calls humanity into religious communion
with the natural world yeah I saw parts
of the movie so without question so huge
into pantheism right but all about the
connection and I always tell the people
this one when they talk about avatar and
they want to know questions about avatar
I find it very interesting that you have
this beautiful planet that's the most
beautiful planet ever created and it's
got a tree in the center of the planet
and everything revolves around this tree
it's like once again life yeah once
again you just hear this like upside
down twisted version of the biblical
account and you know instead of instead
of these demons possessing you you
possess the demons and that was kind of
led to what the movie was so that coming
out is very interesting now let's echo
star wars onboard because there's how
much new-age do you see in the star wars
always was all over the place right no
like I found it very interesting of
course yeah the force that's probably
the thing that the star was is known for
the most and in this Star Wars series
you know they've defined what the force
is but they keep kind of giving you
little bits of information and now it's
like wind George Lucas sold Star Wars to
Disney
there was always kind of separate
in between the light and the dark and
now what Disney's done with it in the
last few Star Wars is that that have
come out is they've now started to blend
them together hmm
so they're basically making the
statement that each each person that
uses the force needs as much darkness as
they do light and you need them both to
be like symbiotically in balance
together it's a-you yeah and they're
pushing everybody into that so have you
guys ever heard of of I need to tug it
here
the official plugged in vodcast you ever
heard of these guys I've heard it
plugged in I've heard of plugged in what
does the plugged in do you plugged in
reviews movies they review movies for
specifically what demographic I thought
it was Christians it is for Christians
so you've got these two guys that
literally go through look at the movies
and try to find all the things that are
you know cautionary with this particular
film and you can tell right away these
guys in the very beginning of this clip
they're very into the Star Wars series
okay so I'm just gonna let the cat out
of the bag right now they're very into
it but I even found it more ironic what
they were actually saying that they saw
in this movie
[Music]
I'm Adam Holtz I'm Paul AC and today
we're gonna talk about Star Wars the
last Jedi Paul you reviewed this movie
for plugged in and I of course saw it
the first night actually I made you go
see it because I want sure I wanted the
responsibility and the burden of
reviewing something that I hoped to love
and turn out I think you loved it more
than I did but that's not gonna be the
main thrust of our podcast we have some
very different ideas on how this movie
works or not but what we want to talk
about here today is really whether it
will work for you and your family and it
does have some tricky elements right
does have some tricky elements and you
know I think the interesting thing is
that after 40 years we're still talking
about the force and after 40 years they
keep introducing sort of tendrils of
meaning to the force that sort of forces
us hahahahahahah to keep having this
conversation right right why don't you
talk about some of the things that are
sort of new wrinkles or things that are
fleshed out with Shergar to the force in
this movie yeah we all know I mean if
you're familiar with the Star Wars
universe at all we understand that the
force has always been a huge component
of its otherwise yes it's part of its
mythos it's of this this energy that
wraps around the entire user energy
field that binds but it is it is this
this super powerful faith he's
describing as this energy force that it
permeates into everything right
it's pantheism right because what did
what did Oprah just say it's everything
everything and God is in everything God
is everything not only in is everything
it's in everything it's in the breath
it's in the life and basically you you
know where the Star Wars series goes if
you just focus your energy you can then
control those elements and then who
becomes the god of basically everything
you can bend it to your will is
basically where they're going with this
you know there's another point is that
you have ascended masters mm-hmm okay
just like you had in the New Age
movement
you have these ascended masters that
direct you and teach you what it means
to be a New Ager so to speak here in the
force in the Star Wars movies you have
these ascended masters of the dark side
and of the light side they even call
them masters exactly mm-hmm I mean
that's really kind of scary when you sit
back you start to think about that
that's how closely it is connected
that's right I mean that is just oh it's
me let's see the next step is chaos if
everyone's got and everyone's control
yes exactly thing well that's why you
have you know the Avengers and all these
other people that are coming up then you
know everybody has these super powers
okay well that's really what an ascended
master has he has super powers he has
these abilities to do things to heal to
do all these other really wonderful
magical things that's what an ascended
master has the ability to do you know
and when you see when when that when the
final conflict comes you're gonna see
these kind of miracles taking place
where Satan's angels will be doing these
kinds of things so what God's people but
they'll recognize it's not them that's a
huge difference it feels to me a lot
like Taoism you know they have this this
philosophy and dowsing which is a is an
Eastern religion system of thought
called methylate the yin-yang
exactly a little yin-yang symbol
Paisley's chasing each other in a circle
so it really does reflect Taoism a lot
and we even see sort of a reflection of
the yin-yang symbol in the moon in that
pool right right we see we see not
exactly but there's there's this
yin-yang type of thing in a pool there
and in in this movie I think that the
thing that that sort of ratchets the
spirituality up in in this particular
movie that we have not seen in the past
is that it's overtly referred to as a
religion it's explicitly called by by
Luke Skywalker as a religion and we see
holy books does he see sacred texts
essentially we see that it has been
disparaging could just be Luke's journal
for all we know because we can't read it
it's somewhere somewhere language so but
but essentially they are sort of
specifying that it is religion which it
has always had those elements but now it
sort of takes the
step forward and that I think causes I
mean it's it's something the parents
need to be aware of right what they're
recognizing is basically that they are
in a sense referencing it as a religion
hmm what's the problem with that
where could this all be going that's
that's what that's sort of really want
to get to the bottom of right now like
like you see all of this this blending
of religions but yet a stepping away
from Jesus where are we going with this
why is this some of the most popular
filmmaking that we have in our world
right now well based on what I
understand you know what the Bible has
to say and what my experience has been
in the new age is that it's actually
it's actually leading to a focal point
okay all these different things that are
taking place you have Maitreya you have
the Buddhist fire to which I was talking
about you know the Avatar and all these
other people that are coming in general
but they're all pointing into one
direction why in other words you have
all these dilip points of darkness I'm
going to call them instead of light okay
bringing people into a particular
specific direction what direction is
that well we know from Scripture that at
one point Satan has to appear as Christ
that's right and what this is doing this
is setting people's minds up on a really
intricate way to receive that deception
over the last days I mean it's really
powerful because all of a sudden you can
say I this is who I am in other words he
is the Buddha reincarnated he is to
Christ he is the Mahdi he is this he is
that all these things are all of a
sudden interlinked he is the one that is
behind the force he is the force okay he
can go ahead and come in and say I am
that person I am the one that's
connecting all these different things
which is what Oprah was talking about
and it makes perfect sense to me if
they're pushing everybody in this like
all inclusive everything else other than
Jesus exactly set Jesus over here and
move everybody over here for when that
day comes that ste will step on this
planet as that Cosmic Christ hmm
everyone's gonna rush to if they're
gonna rush to them because all the other
defense
have been dropped it's like the reversal
of what happened to the Tower of Babel
right so they're there they're unified
God says and if I don't found do
something here there's like nothing they
wouldn't be able to accomplish confounds
all the languages now we're seeing like
the same thing but almost in Reverse
you've got all these religions not just
languages but religions and they're all
leading back to you like a single point
where they could accomplish anything if
they put their mind to it just like he
said it's it's but it's not leading to
Jesus all right its lead you to
something else it's interesting you said
that my wife like she teaches English to
Chinese people and so forth hmm notice
how one language has become almost the
international language in other words in
order for people are communicating you
have to have one basic language what did
God do as you said in Babylon he
confused the languages so you have one
language that unites them you have one
mind or one ability where everybody
comes together one focal point mm-hmm I
mean this is the other thing that's
really struck me because we lived in
China 20 years ago but what's really
struck me is now how how familiar they
are with Hollywood movies right and you
know American pop culture and that
wasn't the case when we were there right
this is their evangelism tool exactly I
mean it literally is the way that
they're spreading their message far and
wide and it's attractive I mean you you
walk into a store when was the last time
you went into Target and it was just
smattered with Jesus stuff hmm you know
what I mean can you imagine can you
imagine but you see the marketing I mean
what if every little kid was wearing a
backpack what's like Bible verses all
smashed around it right and they're
going to school in little outfits that
look like you know Peter and Paul and do
you know what happened right listen what
would you what would you say to the
person who who says man you guys are
taking this way too seriously i watch
these movies as it might escape not
necessarily that it's it's I'm gonna
accept their religion or I'm gonna have
this as a part of my everyday life you
know I think there's a lot of people
that that have that mindset especially
in the Christian commune
that you know this is not going to
change my belief system right but you
have to still consider that that it is
familiarity that we learn so that's how
advertising is so so powerful it's like
it's like over and over and over again
you you get exposed to these certain you
know products or something and it's
through that familiarity that you are
gonna be in the grocery store and when
you go to pick out that that product off
the table
your mind is subconsciously working to
to choose what you're gonna choose
because you got a lot of different
choices so the danger that I see here is
you are subconsciously planting opposite
thoughts of what the Bible is trying to
build up the way is Jesus Christ these
the only way and our relationship should
be with him and if we're listening to
all of these new-age thoughts and
everything which are totally competing
from that I think enough of that over
the course of time there will be a
moment that that decision will be needed
to be made and it's it's gonna be a
confusing decision I guarantee you when
Satan steps on the scene it's not gonna
be like oh I know who he is you know
what I mean
if you don't understand and are able to
discern what the character of Jesus and
Christ's mission and all that is all of
this stuff is just gonna play into that
confusion and I think it's gonna have a
non subconscious level
a lot of what Hollywood Hollywood puts
out these guys are it's a teaching tool
to them you know it's not just well
let's have some fun we're gonna put a
movie together you know you can find
multiple statements from multiple
directors and producers where they're
like I didn't believe that so I'm going
to do it this way you know when it comes
to a Bible movie or or there you'll take
a character that's a superhero no
religious affiliation and then they'll
tell you like all this stuff that they
put in about God and their thoughts
about God it's like wait a minute
like where did all that come from
because they want to teach you something
there they're really giving you their
viewpoint if you're gonna consume
somebody else's viewpoint all day long
instead of God's viewpoint it's like
what are you gonna wind up believing and
let's swing it back all the way to the
beginning of the conversation how did
you
get into the New Age how did you get
there it happened you but but you read
books and you read watch media and and
so whereas a lot of people say you know
what I'm strong we'll do this hey the
reality of the situation is most people
probably aren't reading their Bible
most people are surface skimming they
know the popular texts but most people
don't sit down and really spend time
every day reading their Bible and I
think this is a danger competing with
that and in world war two you like
Hitler one of the things that he did to
gain popular you know opinion was he
started pumping stuff into the school
system and you know and it was rally and
all the kids and they're like yeah this
idea and that idea and they're all on
board with Hitler and it's like well duh
and he used media as one of his
strongest ways to influence an entire
nation that the Jews were nothing more
than rats yeah how did he do that it was
just literally influential media
neuro-linguistic programming China okay
we the enemy of souls has taken that to
a new art he's gone and broadened that
whole understanding of what that really
means because it's not only what you see
that affects you it's what you hear
daily on a one-to-one basis that affects
you it's it's see we think that just
going ahead and watching the movie it's
okay but you know what it starts to
program your mind
alright those small little inserts I go
in and and they touch your mind and they
and then bring you in that focus and
then you begin to realize hey this is a
really scary situation what you read
affects how you look at life all those
different things start to make a
difference so when if you've been fed a
lie and you think it's the truth and you
don't realize that you've been fed that
lie for a long time what happens you buy
right into it so when the enemy of souls
appears where he says that you know he
actually will almost like appear like
he's walking on earth Christ doesn't say
when the Bible teach us that he doesn't
do that that we go up to meet him he
doesn't come down here you know and if
you're not programmed or if you haven't
studied your Bible you're not gonna
realize that and you'll be taken in by
the deception because there'll be such a
magnificent
presence of powerful presence remember
my wife was talking about earlier about
you know there was this crescendo that
Billups and then all of a sudden the
Guru appeared right and what you're
watching is this crescendo that the
enemy of souls is orchestrating on a
level that we've never seen before and
he will appear at the apex and people
will just go that's him that's what
we've been waiting for exactly Wow yeah
I mean you think about that in the
reverse side when when when Christ was
being walked to you know crucifixion and
and the frenzy that was going on there
and the demons were running around you
know crucify him crucify him in human
form I mean that's that's he he has the
ability to get the crowd going everybody
jumps on that bandwagon and yeah like
you experienced everybody's in over the
Guru and you kind of feed off of the way
everybody else is is interacting with
that that's scary
it is very scary I want to show you guys
how this this ends up because I think
it's very interesting how they come to
this conclusion about the Star Wars
series but it's like they they I mean
it's a pretty harsh Caloocan conclusion
but it's like but we're still gonna
watch it do you feel for me these
elements of the force have always been
potentially navigable for some families
do you would you agree with that is that
still navigable hearing I think so and
this is more my personal opinion than
plugged-in i think all movies present a
worldview that you have to decide as a
family are we willing to wade into this
or not now this one's a little bit
skewed because I saw Star Wars when I
was seven right right and my parents
weren't really worried about whether the
world view was appropriate to me as a
seven-year-old so I've grown up with
Star Wars and that probably causes me
perhaps to minimize it a little bit
personally you know if Star Wars came
out now would I have a different
perspective on the world view than I did
I grew up with it right probably right
you know I think this is a great sort of
case study in Whoopie because it's so
clearly a belief system that's different
than Christianity okay so they're
clearly admitting that these movies are
absolutely different than Christianity
so my question then why would you watch
it yeah doesn't make sense and there so
there's a lot of stuff like that there's
an interesting text in the second
thessalonians says this it says the
coming of the lawless one is according
to the working of satan with all power
and signs and lying wonders okay so
those are very powerful elements and
with unrighteous deception among those
who perish because they did not receive
the love of the truth that they might be
saved and for this reason God will send
them strong delusion that they should
believe the lie in other words there's a
lie coming all right a very powerful lie
it's coming to everybody and if you
don't love the truth God is gonna let
you go down your own path to believe
that lie right you're gonna wind up
believing and you know we hear this all
the time it's not gonna affect me what
they really say by that is nothing will
change my thinking but everything you
watch everything you read is designed to
change your thinking right art is meant
to affect the user that's the purpose of
art and I look at something like Star
Wars and I'm like okay it is if George
Lucas isn't Christian and he talks about
all these New Age ideas and he doesn't I
mean I've seen interviews or he's just
like he doesn't even know what's out
there you believe there's something but
he doesn't know what it is he doesn't
know what to call it then don't call it
Christian right don't try to make it
Christian don't try to pull all these
Christian themes out of there because
it's not it wasn't designed that way
that's right like you can't make it
something that it's not that's right
like he said it's it's it's Taoism it's
it's pantheism it's all these other
things so you can't just be like oh well
it's got a good and an evil guy oh
therefore it's like Christ and Satan
right you know I mean it's it's it's
pushing more towards that religion God
is in everything in the force and all
that kind of stuff than it is
you cannot model that after Christ it's
super important to understand what the
people believe that are putting stuff
out so I'm gonna go back to some things
that you brought out in the very
beginning there is a quote from the book
The Secret Doctrine which always written
by Blavatsky and this comes from page 79
she says the devil is now called
darkness by the church whereas in the
Bible he is called the son of God the
bright star or the early morning or yeah
buttburn star the early morning Lucifer
there is a whole philosophy of dogmatic
craft and the reason why the first art
angel who sprang from the depths of
chaos was called Lux the luminous son of
the morning or main bandra dawn he was
transformed by the church and to Lucifer
or Satan now here's the kicker listen to
her reasoning because he is higher and
older than Jehovah and had to be
sacrificed to the new dogma well so when
you start talking about these authors
and ascended masters and they're gonna
teach you these things and it's like
well where is all this coming from you
have to understand they may throw out
terms and they sound like the same terms
and they sound like they mean the same
things hmm but let's go back to the root
definition and root cause what are they
really talking about and when you when
you see here now if she's gonna refer to
the Christ in any way I know what she's
talking about she's not talking about
God right she's talking about another
master right and that's where you know
all those hip-hop stars all those actors
you know and they reference God like
yeah which God are you actually
referencing you know the going back to
the Theosophical Society it's very
interesting that the the original trust
was called the Lucifer trust mmm-hmm and
then they change it to the lucious trust
mmm okay so the core and with that which
is recognizing what you just said just a
moment ago her focal point is
recognizing Lucifer and that's really
what the lucious trust is now all about
which is where
now it's right there at the United
Nations as Gary I heard a really
interesting story this past weekend
somebody was describing I think it was
this this special operation from our
government that would teach people how
to spot counterfeits and they did all
this training and they were trying to
teach this this this group that was
basically in taking large amounts of
cash and the ladies that would take in
all the cash they they basically came to
the training and they said we don't
really need that and so the the FBI was
like well why not like where do we need
to train you how to do it they said we
handle so much of the genuine you can
put a fake in our hands and we will spot
it in a second because we are so
familiar with the genuine and I just
kind of stuck with me and I was just
like wow you know it's like it's like
yeah the more that you focus on all
these other stories and all these other
things going on and and as fantastical
as they may sound it's just like you're
not focusing on the genuine and when you
really fall in love with the genuine and
then you hear these fantastical things
and you go hey that doesn't really line
up it's like you don't even want that in
your head and that's like that's the
thing that I question with like you know
even even these guys I don't know where
they are spiritually but I found it very
interesting that they were like look man
these Star Wars movies they have nothing
to do with Christianity but I'm gonna go
watch them you know you have this desire
to be satisfied on some kind of level
that you don't realize that you've been
actually programmed to do that yeah yeah
awesome well any last little minute
thoughts you guys want to throw out
there I have a question while being in
the New Age is there one truth that you
wish you had known that would have
gotten you out of it quicker that's an
interesting question
mm-hmm if I understood the sin aspect of
it and what it really meant to be a
Christian that I can't accomplish I
can't overcome those things in my own
accord that this submission to Christ
was a requirement you know I went I was
in the Lutheran Church and my mom would
you say that was absolutely fascinated
by what the pastor would have to say but
when I heard him talk about certain
things might I what my whole aspect
would deflate
in regards to truth that I'd read in the
Bible and taking the Bible literally as
it reads which is what we're encouraged
to do take the Bible just as it reads
really what it made a difference in my
life
hmm and I think that's really what it
comes down to I think that people don't
realize that the Bible as it is written
is really designed to teach us about a
relationship with not only God but with
one another mm-hmm and it shows us what
happens if we don't follow that way you
know the children of Israel were when
went in this direction of of really
Satan's leading okay when it comes down
to it instead of following God's leading
which would have given them peace and
happiness and that's really what the
issue was for me if I had actually
understood this better when I was
growing up because when I in the
Lutheran Church I recognized the
commandments of God and I can remember
our pastor talking about Hellfire I'm
going oh you know because I recognized
that that wasn't really true what the
Bible is teaching and this is just as a
child okay because you recognize certain
things that are not true because the
Bible doesn't teach that and so you from
my perspective if I had heard something
that was about real true Christianity
that I can understand the Word of God
and that the Holy Spirit will be my
teacher because that's what the Bible
teaches me instead of man then all of a
sudden and that's what all these things
are looking for you're looking for an
ascended master to teach you right
you're looking for someone to teach you
well there is one right interesting a
good point there is one and his name is
the Holy Spirit he's come here to teach
us about Christ
exactly mm-hmm good point
wow what a great note I don't even know
if there's anything else that we should
say after this I hope you guys are
blessed you know kind of getting to know
Randi and Julia here with the new age
and your your journey out of that and
into Christianity what a beautiful
testimony I want to encourage you
listeners out there especially if you
have young kids man I have looked
through tons of testimonies in YouTube
and there is time and time again kids
are
the ages of 12 13 and 14 years old that
started getting into the whole New Age
movement simply by watching little
particular movies that have those
elements in them or listening to some
people on YouTube so you know it's not
necessarily just a movie be careful what
your children are watching even on
YouTube things can be somewhat unsafe
and so you know we wanted to give you a
little context of this because coming up
here in this holiday season there is
some major movies coming out and a lot
of them have a lot of New Age philosophy
in it so do your research keep checking
out our LEDs and hopefully you watch a
couple of them watch a few of the other
ones we've got one on Star Wars and and
then I'll give you a whole context of
what we're talking about but hit that
notification bell we'll give you a
notification when there was new videos
that drop and do you haven't subscribed
please subscribe those of you that have
thank you for watching thank you to all
for supporting us we hope you have a
blessed weekend god bless
[Music]